Kostenloser Nahverkehr?
Gibt es schon!
Mit der Schwarzfahrkarte!
OFF: Cut!
Kostenloser Nahverkehr?
Gibt es schon!
Mit der Schwarzfahrkarte!
OFF: Cut!
Kostenloser Nahverkehr?
Gibt es schon!
Mit der Schwarzfahrkarte!
OFF: Aaah! Cut!
Leute, ich glaube, ich bin einfach nicht gemacht
für Werbung!
Melbourne hat es, Tallinn auch.
Kostenlosen Nahverkehr!
Wie machen diese Städte dieses Wunder möglich?
Tallinn erlaubt nur Tallinnern eine kostenlose
Fahrt.
Das hat dazu geführt, dass mehr Leute sich
in der Stadt registriert haben.
Höhere Steuereinnahmen durch mehr offizielle
Stadtbewohner.
Unter dem Strich sagen beide Städte, dass
sie sogar ein Plus machen.
Die Frage ist: Könnte kostenloser Nahverkehr
auch in Deutschland funktionieren?
Was? Die Frage ist bescheuert, natürlich funktioniert
das!
Ah, ok.
Achso, das Video muss mindestens drei Minuten
lang werden?
270.000 Menschen werden jedes Jahr in Deutschland
beim Schwarzfahren erwischt.
Das sind fast so viele Menschen wie Bielefeld
Einwohner hat.
Das gibt's doch gar nicht.
OFF: Was, Bielefeld?
Nein, dass so viele Menschen beim Schwarzfahren
erwischt werden!
Die Mehrheit der Schwarzfahrer macht das nicht
aus Spaß, sondern aus Armut.
Es sei denn, man ist nur zum Spaß arm, aber
dass Armut eine Entscheidung ist,
glauben höchstens FDP-Wähler.
Zwar gibt es in Deutschland Sozialtickets,
aber der Rabatt reicht nicht:
Im Hartz 4-Regelsatz sind 34,66 € für Verkehr
vorgesehen, in Hamburg kostet die ermäßigte
Monatskarte aber zum Beispiel 85,30 €.
Arschkarte statt Fahrkarte.
Es ist in Deutschland möglich, dass man sich
die 1,50 € für die Kurzfahrkarte nicht leisten kann,
dann 60 € Strafe zahlen muss,
und weil man das erst recht nicht zahlen kann,
ins Gefängnis kommt und der Staat dann 150 €
pro Tag pro Häftling ausgibt.
Das ist mal eine Preissteigerung!
So, und jetzt ein Witz:
Unterhalten sich drei Häftlinge.
Sagt der Erste: „Ich habe jemanden ermordet.“
Sagt der Zweite: „Ich habe jemanden ausgeraubt.“
Sagt der Dritte: „Ich konnte mir meine Fahrkarte nicht leisten.“
Das ist ein Scheiß-Witz!
Für die geschätzten 100 Milliarden Euro
Steuern, die in Deutschland jährlich hinterzogen werden,
könnte man auch den öffentlichen
Nahverkehr zehn Mal finanzieren.
Man könnte statt Fahrkartenkontrolleuren
auch einfach Steuerfahnder einstellen.
Logisch: Jemand der Deutschland nutzt, ohne
dafür zu zahlen, sollte bestraft werden.
Dieser Abschnitt war jetzt extrem populistisch.
Aber steckt nicht in jedem Populismus auch
ein bisschen Wahrheit?
Nein!
Trotzdem, hier stimmt's.
Warum zahle ich für Theater mit, wenn ich
da selbst gar nicht hingehe?
Warum zahle ich für den Verfassungsschutz
mit, wenn ich gar kein Nazi bin?
Wenn ich Glück habe, werde ich in meinem
Leben niemals auf Hilfe von Feuerwehr, Krankenhäusern
oder vom Jobcenter angewiesen sein.
Aber ich finde es gut, dass es das gibt.
Umgekehrt könnte man es natürlich auch machen.
Wenn schon der Öffentliche Nahverkehr Geld
kostet, dann könnte man auch Geld nehmen
für das Benutzen einer Ampel oder einer Schaukel.
Wie teuer ist zum Beispiel Stau für die Gesellschaft?
Der ADAC beziffert die indirekten und direkten
Kosten von Stau auf 79,8 Milliarden Euro.
Das sind fast 60 Milliarden Euro mehr, als der
gesamte Öffentliche Nahverkehr in Deutschland kostet.
Auf 3,5 Metern Straße können pro Stunde
2.000 Menschen in Autos befördert werden.
Die Straßenbahn transportiert im gleichen
Zeitraum 22.000 Passagiere.
Autoverkehr ist also aus Sicht der Allgemeinheit
nicht nur die teuerste Form der Fortbewegung,
sonder auch noch die dümmste.
Fazit: Schwarzfahren muss bezahlbar bleiben.